hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
elizabeth holmes was the darling of
silicon valley a brilliant thinker a
fearless empowerment icon she envisioned
a revolutionary product called the
edison that could fit on a desk and yet
perform over a thousand medical tests
and diagnoses with a single drop of
blood
no longer was testing slow and
cumbersome with big machines it was the
iphone of the medical field
despite having no medical degree and
dropping out of university elizabeth was
featured on the cover of forbes and
fortune magazine
everyone from the walton family to
rupert murdoch was jumping on board to
invest her company theranos was going to
revolutionize medicine the theronos
board included the former ceo of wells
fargo and the former u.s secretary of
state henry kissinger at its peak
theranos managed to master a company
valuation of 10 billion
but it wasn't to last
in 2015 the wall street journal
published a series of articles that
suggested that its devices were flawed
and inaccurate and from there skepticism
began to grow the theranos story was one
of the biggest scandals of the 2010s and
it was one of the most viewed episodes
on this channel so if you need to brush
up on the entire story be sure to watch
the original episode first
in 2018 holmes was indicted by the
department of justice federal
prosecutors accused the 37 year old of
defrauding investors doctors and
patients
holmes pled not guilty to nine wire
fraud counts and two conspiracy camps
there's a possible prison sentence of up
to 20 years for each conviction
she also faces a fine of 250 000 plus
restitution for each count her trial
started in august of 2021 and earlier in
the week she was found guilty on four
counts
in this episode we'll take a look at how
it all went down
[Music]
you are watching
tv
after the 2018 indictment elizabeth
holmes mostly went under the radar
but in 2019 she was spotted in san
francisco with her new partner luxury
hotel heir billy evans
elizabeth holmes might be facing up to
20 years in prison but she sure looks
happy prancing around san francisco
that's the disgraced tycoon and her
fiance billy evans holmes has been
arrested and charged with massive fraud
elizabeth a lot of young women looked up
to you especially in tech what would you
have to say to those young women
she wouldn't be running free for long
though
when the trial did begin in 2021 the
main crux of the case was as follows did
elizabeth holmes knowingly deceive or
was she just a struggling entrepreneur
desperately buying some time to fix a
product in good faith
the question here was intent
as james melendrez a former federal
prosecutor told wired magazine quote the
battleground is holmes's mental state
whether or not she had the intent to
commit fraud you have 12 jurors 12
people off the street who sit in a room
and decide what was in holmes's mind
witnesses included former employees who
had stated that holmes knowingly covered
up the fact that the machines that she
was touting didn't work the courts found
that holmes convinced investors to pile
in money by faking demos exaggerating
claims and printing pharmaceutical
company logos on theranos reports to
make them appear legitimate she even
made a claim of having a contract of the
us military to boost the company's image
during the proceedings all was laid bare
emails text messages internal documents
you name it
it all pointed to what we suspected
theranos was an absolute catastrophe
the government's first witness at the
holmes fraud trial was theranos
financial controller denise yam
when yam testified against theranos it
painted a bleak picture
the company had net losses of 16.2
million in 2010
27.2 million in 2011 57 million in 2012
and 92 million in 2013 the company made
no revenue in 2012 and 2013 and burned
through two million dollars per week in
2013. yam testified that theranos went
for years without having its financial
statements audited
by 2015 theranos had accumulated losses
of 585 million but a document was given
to investors that forecasted a revenue
for 2014 of 140 million and a revenue
for 2015 of 990 million former fisa
scientist shane webber took the stand he
testified that elizabeth holmes used the
pfizer logo in investor materials
without the company's permission the
purpose was to make theranos appear more
credible particularly in a study aimed
at validating their blood testing device
prosecutors stated that it was part of a
sham to convince walgreens to invest and
it worked walgreens invested 140 million
dollars in the blood testing company
holmes had placed the fisa logo at the
top of each page of a cancer study
report before sending it to walgreens
executives
the court was also shown an investor
booklet one page said quote theranos has
been comprehensively validated over the
course of the last seven years by 10 of
the 15 largest pharmaceutical companies
with hundreds of thousands of tests
processed
another witness former theronus employee
erica chuang took the stand
elizabeth claimed that the therinos
devices could do over a thousand tests
but according to erica in reality they
could do just 12 and not very well
she spoke about the large rate of
inaccuracies in theranos devices saying
that they regularly failed quality
control analysis executives would then
encourage scientists to cherry-pick and
manipulate data to make the results seem
more accurate than they were
because the therianos machines worked so
poorly most of the tests were done on
third-party machines
a nurse practitioner from arizona
testified that theranos machines were
giving wildly inconsistent blood results
there was one case where she had a
pregnant patient in her practice the
theronos machines gave mystifying
results which indicated that the
patient's pregnancy was going to fail
the patient who also testified
eventually successfully delivered a baby
the experience left nurse zackerman
quote very uncertain as to the validity
of the results
she also stated that she felt very
uncomfortable continuing to use the
services
it's important to note that medical
decisions can be based off the results
of blood tests so it's not a stretch to
say that holmes was potentially
endangering patients lives with her
faulty theronos devices
elizabeth holmes took the stand for
seven days
over this period she deflected blame
repeatedly she blamed her ex-boyfriend
and former business partner sunny
balwani for falsifying financial reports
she went on to say that he abused her
causing her mental anguish affecting her
performance and judgment at the company
elizabeth also blamed theranoss's
scientific advisors and therons's board
for the company's failings
prosecutors also focused on sunny and
elizabeth's luxurious lifestyle they
went on to describe how elizabeth holmes
traveled on private jets stayed in
luxury hotels and also of her reliance
on multiple assistants who took care of
home decorating clothes shopping and
jewelry
elizabeth holmes once celebrated as the
youngest self-made female billionaire in
the world left court a convicted felon
clutching the hands of her parents and
husband late monday a jury found her
guilty of four fraud related counts
after seven days of deliberations a jury
in san jose california found elizabeth
holmes guilty on four counts of why
fraud and conspiracy to commit white
fraud wire fraud in this case just means
fraud where the method of money transfer
from investors to theranos was a wire
transfer
the jury returned a verdict of not
guilty on another four counts and they
couldn't reach a unanimous verdict on
three
as mentioned holmes could be facing up
to 20 years for each conviction and a
combined one million dollar fine for the
four counts
so these charges mostly relate to the
investors and many say that it doesn't
account for the wrong doing against
patients who received bogus blood
results or other partners such as
walgreens who took faulty theranos
machines into their stores
but the thing that many people wonder is
how could she have gotten away with this
for so long in the first place many
further questions need to be asked
theranos was a classic story of hype
over substance
the reckless behaviour of sunny and
elizabeth holmes destroyed many
opportunities for legitimate research in
the field of multi-test blood work
now other companies working on this
problem will forever be looked at with
skepticism
speaking of which what were the issues
with the therianos multi-test medical
technology
well there are three main ones
number one getting reliable results from
a single drop of blood
number two performing multiple tests
with a single drop of blood and number
three shrinking the machine down to a
desktop size
so for the first one the idea of
performing a battery of tests from a
single drop of blood isn't new though
there are multiple medical studies that
state that the results of a single drop
of blood is intrinsically inconsistent
for example concentrations of things
such as white blood cell count and
hemoglobin can vary from drop to drop
when obtained from a finger
for the second issue running multiple
tests from a single drop of blood
appears to be impossible with current
technology right now to receive results
either compounds have to be added to the
blood or they have to be spun in a
centrifuge and sometimes other invasive
methods are used
so once these things are done it
destroys the ability for repeat testing
lastly shrinking the machine down to a
desktop size may have been possible but
only for a few select tests not the
thousands of tests that were claimed and
this is what most companies that dare to
remain in the field are working on today
and with that that's just about where
the theronoff story ends sunny balwani's
trial will be in the future
but for now the courts have decided that
elizabeth holmes was indeed trying to
scam investors out of billions and now
she could be facing decades in jail
so what do you guys think about the
verdict do you think she deserved more
or do you think justice was served
feel free to discuss in the comment
section below or in the cold fusion
discord
anyway that's about it from me hope you
all had a great christmas and new years
and i do hope to bring a lot of good
stuff this year on this channel this has
been to go though and you've been
watching cold fusion
thanks for watching and i'll see you
again soon for the next episode cheers
guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
cold fusion
it's me thinking